you live in your lair you fry and you
cry hey guys it's Alex and today I'm
gonna be taking you behind the scenes at
tasty to show you how to make a
mozzarella stick lasagna
[Music]
you all know I can get a little messy in
the kitchen so today I'm gonna try to
stay on top about mess with help from
scotch-brite keyword try okay so I'm
gonna start by making the pasta yes I'm
going to be making this pasta from
scratch because this ain't no regular
mozzarella stick is on you I'm gonna
start with three cups of flour and then
I'm gonna sprinkle that with a teaspoon
of salt so now you have to make like a
little well in the center of the flour
I'm gonna put three eggs right in the
center of the well you have to be a
little careful so that the eggs stay in
the well because you're gonna have a
mess otherwise now just a tablespoon of
olive oil right on there so now I'm very
carefully going to start beating the
eggs and I'll slowly incorporate the
flour into them but again you have to do
this very carefully because you don't
want any of your eggs start leaking out
and break the damn wall the wall is like
a dam you can slowly start to
incorporate the flour from the well into
the middle and start to thicken it up so
it starts turning into a dough I don't
know what this hand is doing just in
case and don't worry if it's a little
lumpy at first it'll turn into a smooth
beautiful pasta dough don't be afraid of
the best is my you know what that's why
you put on an apron let's turn in to
more of like a dough at this point just
keep gathering it together I feel like I
always make things that end up being
worth like a workout cooking is supposed
to be enjoyable so I'm gonna knead this
dough for about 10 more minutes then
we're gonna let it rest and then it
should be good to roll out okay
so our dough has rested this will help
allow your flour in the dough to hydrate
so before I start rolling this out I am
gonna cut our dough into four pieces I'm
gonna first roll that out a little so
then I'm going to start feeding this
through our pasta roller
[Music]
kind of tough oh I already messed
something up you actually need to start
at the lowest setting because that is
like the widest setting and you
gradually get smaller and smaller and
smaller
I started up six where I'm actually
supposed to start up one no the end of
the world I'm just gonna put this back
together all right so we're on one I'm
going to start yeah that's much easier
now as your pasta gets thin you have to
just be a little bit more gentle with it
it's just a little trickier as it gets
longer almost there
just get that out of there don't want it
to stick together but okay no matter
what
listen it's lasagna though so you know
you just layer that stuff you know what
a little bit right so I am going to just
feed it through with this hand but then
I'm gonna switch to this hand and keep
it flat rather than letting it Bunch
on top of itself food grabbing it over
here
yeah so not letting it ribbon up
underneath the pasta maker is making
like a world of a difference alright
number seven almost there
yeah that one went a lot smoother so the
way they say you know your pasta is done
is when you can just barely see through
it and look you can see my hand just
gonna put that on here keep it moving
okay time for the sauce which is I guess
these you're part of this whole recipe
so first I'm gonna add a little bit so
ideally just about a tablespoon of oil
but this is fine now I'm gonna add in my
onions I'm gonna let these kind of
soften up before I add in anything else
you can always just use regular marinara
sauce if you're making this recipe at
home but you're already gonna go through
the trouble of making your homemade
pasta you might as well make a fresh
sauce right all right so now that the
onions have softened up and our little
translucent I'm gonna add in our garlic
right in there get that going for a
couple more minutes I'm also gonna throw
in some of our salts and now we are
ready for our tomatoes just gonna pour
that all right in there good thing I'm
wearing an apron over my white shirt and
lastly our Italian seasoning so now I'm
just gonna let this simmer for about 30
minutes just to bring all those flavors
together and that's our sauce all right
moving on to our mozzarella sticks so we
have flour our egg wash which is egg and
water
and then our panko so before we start
I'm also gonna add some seasonings to
our panko so I have some onion powder
some garlic powder some dried parsley
some dried oregano and some salts so
just
mix that up so now we're gonna dredge
our mozzarella sticks in our breading so
dredging can be kind of a messy process
but there are a couple of tricks that
you can use to keep it a little more
clean which is using both of your hands
so one of your hands will be a dry hand
and one of your hand
will be a wet tent although I always mix
them up so wet it into their wet hand
there and got our first one okay so the
reason we're going back into the egg
after the panko is just to get that
extra layer of that breading on there so
that when we fry it it will be all nice
and golden and crispy so now I'm gonna
pop these in the freezer so they can set
before we fry okay time to fry so I'm
gonna start just flop on them in here to
this oil so I'm looking to get a nice
golden brown color on the outside and a
nice gooey cheesy melty Center on the
inside it seems like the oil may be a
little bit too hot because these are
cooking pretty fast we've got a really
nice golden brown color but we've got no
cheese plus we need to lower the
temperature of the oil so that the
inside of the mozzarella stick has a
chance to melt before the outside
completely burns all right so I've
brought my oil temperature down to about
325 so this should be better in making
sure our cheese melts before the outside
gets nice golden brown
frying can be a little intimidating to
some people I always encourage you to
use a thermometer when you're frying
just stay pretty like organized and
clean which isn't really my strong suit
but all right so we've got these all
fried I'm just gonna test one to make
sure we've got that cheese pull yes
look at that alright now that we finally
got our mozzarella sticks right it's
time to layer our lasagna so I'm gonna
start with our red sauce go at the
bottom of the pan and now we're gonna
add our noodles so you could really
layer this however you feel called to
but this is how I'm gonna do it now I'm
gonna start with our ricotta now I'm
gonna add some spinach cuz you know we
gotta say a little healthy among all
this cheese some basil lovely and then
some shredded mozzarella cheese now I'm
gonna add a couple more layers of noodle
or fresh-made pasta it's looking so good
so now I'm going to add a little bit
more of our marinara sauce and this is
the fun layer because we're gonna be
adding our mozzarella sticks in here
this is crazy
but I'm crazy so now I'm gonna put a
little bit more sauce on top of these
yumm it actually smells so good I'm
drooling or salivating subtly it kind of
cooks let's get a little messy but
that's ok so no with another layer of
our noodle to the another layer of our
ricotta or greens
[Music]
our final layer of pasta beautiful and
then one last little bit of marinara on
top just you know hide any of those
mistakes and of course top it off with a
little bit more shredded cheese and
voila
all right so now I'm going to pop this
in the oven at bake our lasagna for
about 30 minutes which is the perfect
amount of time for me to get going on
cleaning up this mess
so to clean up I'm going to be using the
new scotch brite soap control dish wand
it has a button right here to control
when and where you use soap there's also
a scraper on the back for stuck on food
I don't generally love doing dishes but
this dish wand makes it a whole lot
easier
[Music]
all right look at that it looks and
smells so good I can't wait to cut into
this thing the most satisfying part of
making lasagna getting to see all those
layers oh yeah all right now for the
best part we get to try it
[Music]